smearing powdered dye all over each
other to celebrate the festival of color
Holi heralds the end of winter and start
of spring and these people in the
capital weren't letting warnings about
coronavirus get in the way of their
celebrations or we're going to collect
here regardless of age regardless of
religion creed and we're going to color
each other have a very good time have
very good very good lunch also but
elsewhere Indians are concerned of the
dozens of confirmed cases so far from
Kerala and the south to Indian
administered Kashmir in the north
Kashmiri parents are appealing to the
government to airlift their children
from universities in Iran Iran has one
of the highest number of covert 19 cases
outside China we are very concerned
about our children about the fate of
virtual know who are stranded in Iran
they had gone for a medical education we
are very hopeful I mean that the
Government of India would do something
very seriously in bringing our children
back to India two thousand Indians there
in waiting evacuation flights from Iran
and Indian industries of feeling the
effects to India is the world's biggest
supplier of generic drugs but most of
the ingredients come from China without
raw material we can't do the production
that's why we have curtailed our
products and activities since Chinese
imports stopped
India's government banned the export of
26 medicines including paracetamol to
keep the home market supplied consumer
today effect article admin a border
consumers haven't been affected yet but
if this continues for the next one or
two months the consumer will definitely
feel the effect and more than with
pricing will feel the effect of the
shortens the pharmaceutical industry is
urging the government to allow imports
of ingredients from countries other than
China while that will take time the
government has ordered immediate
measures including closing all primary
schools in Delhi and indeed administered
Kashmir and screening all airline
passenger arrivals
but policing what happens in public
places is easier than in people's homes
despite Prime Minister Narendra Modi
saying he
to be celebrating Holi this year and
Delhi's Chief Minister asking people to
stay away from crowds the show of
defiance is an indication of just how
difficult it will be to contain an
outbreak amongst 1.3 billion people
Elisabeth puranam al Jazeera New Delhi